dark fate takes the terminated franchise
back to basics resetting the timeline
back to the end of Terminator 2
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video we're diving deep into
Terminator dark fate to analyze the
ending the new timeline and what it
really means for the future of the
franchise plus I'll explain the
intriguing way Arnold Schwarzenegger
Scarl connects to the t800 from
Terminator 2 and my predictions on how
the new Skynet Legion will be defeated
in possible sequels there will of course
be spoilers for dark fate and other
movies in the franchise although it's
the sixth Terminator movie dark fate is
a direct sequel to Terminator to the
events of T to mean that Skynet no
longer exists in the new film however
the unstoppable March of artificial
intelligence means a new AI system
called Legion goes bad
instead Legion then sends a rev1980 back
in time from the future to assassinate
Danny the Future leader of the
resistance in this new timeline the Rev
9 racks of a brutal body counts and is
relentless in its pursuit because it can
recover from virtually any physical
damage including being sent through a
turbine in the final showdown as a final
resort augmented human grace tells Danny
she must use her power source to fry the
machines neural net processor removing
the power source from grace kills her
but Danny is able to jam it into the
revenant skull short-circuiting many of
its functions to finish the killer
cyborg off an injured Carl reactivates
and holds the killer cyborg down while
the power source burns them up shutting
both of them down effectively killing
them this ending combines a finale of
Terminator 2 when the t800 came back to
life after its secondary power source
activated to rescue John Connor from the
t1000 and the ending of Terminator 3
rise of the machines were like Danny the
t 850 jammed its own power source into
the skull of the TX Terminator you are
terminated
with the rf9 defeated the future
resistance leader danny has been saved
was a future apocalypse where the AI
system legion turns against its human
creator still hasn't been avoided so
it's similar to the first Terminator
movie where John Connors future is saved
but the apocalypse isn't to prevent it
in the very final scene of dark fate
Danny watch as a young grace he's still
alive in the present day and she vows to
Sarah that she won't let grace die for
her again in other words Danny wants to
break the time loop that in the future
forces her to send adult grace back in
time to die for her this final
playground scene is also a Kula march to
the iconic scene from Judgment Day where
Sara had an apocalyptic vision of the
future and foresaw the nuclear
catastrophe that Skynet would inflict on
the world dark fate linked that moment
from t2 which was what drove Sarah to
prevent the rise of Skynet with Danny's
own decision to change the future and
stop the rise of Legion so dark fate
leaves the future open to change making
the new sequel to Terminator 2 a lot
more hopeful and optimistic than
Terminator 3 rise of the machines
the original sequel which took a
fatalistic view that despite everything
Sarah Connor did to stop Judgment Day
and t2 Armageddon at the hands of Skynet
was unavoidable we stopped Judgment Day
you're only postponed it Judgment Day is
inevitable that third film killed off
Sarah Connor and finished with the
nuclear apocalypse that had been averted
in t2 I should have realized our destiny
was never to stop Judgment Day it was
merely to survive it Dok fate by
contrast actually reveals that there's a
glimmer of hope and the future of
artificial intelligence may not be as
catastrophic as seen in previous sequels
after t2 Dark fates call is the perfect
example of how a destructive AI machine
can actually become a friend to humans
and actively work to do good Carr was a
t800 that was sent back by Skynet
together with other terminators to make
sure that one of them completed the
mission to assassinate John Connor
before Karl got to John the events of
Terminator 2 destroyed Cyberdyne and the
existence of Skynet was erased from the
future despite this as a machine Karl
had to follow the mission he'd been
programmed to perform first after he
kills johnny has no
other instructions from Skynet so he
follows his other program directive
which is to blend in with human society
so he can carry out any missions
covertly
and with over 20 years of continuous
machine learning about human society
under his belt Karl is transformed into
something almost human
in fact Cole's evolution can be seen as
what would have happened to the t800
from Terminator 2
it hasn't sacrificed itself at the end
of that movie in t2 Uncle Bob as John
Connor nicknamed him learned over the
course of just a few days how to become
more human even picking up slang no
problemo
hasta la vista baby another interesting
parallel between carl and bob is how
they both became benevolent father
figures Carl helped rescue a woman and
her charge of an abusive husband and
when he talks about how reliable he is
it echoes what Sarah thought of the t800
from Terminator 2 watching John with the
Machine it was suddenly so clear the
Terminator would never stop it would
always be there of all the would-be
fathers who came and went over the years
this thing this machine was the only one
who measured up and as a measure of how
human karl has become notice how in dark
fate we see the machines sitting
comfortably next to the family's dog
this is in stark contrast to what was
established in the first Terminator
movie the dogs instinctively bark and
get nervous when a terminator was nearby
as they have an ability to detect
infiltrator units I was dreaming about
dogs we use them to spot terminators
call even seems to acquired a form of
his own free will when he meets Sarah he
tells her that because she chose to
change the future
Skynet's now no longer exists meaning
that he's been set free because he has
no further orders to follow and now he's
choosing to make his own autonomous
decision to protect Dani I'm going to
help you protect the girl because I
choose to Khan's freedom and ability to
make his own decisions also fits well
with the phrase no fate but what we make
that first appeared in t2 the future is
nuts
there is no fate but what we make for
ourselves this is echoed again in Doc
fates flash-forward scenes from the
future where Danny rescues grace from
attackers who are after her food Danny
tells the other humans that they
shouldn't be fighting amongst themselves
but joining together to fight machines
instead when one of them says there's no
point as they can't win Danny urges them
to resist fate a belief that rallies
people to her cause and builds and
armies is fighting to take the world
back from the machines so given the
terrifying future we see in Doc fates
flash-forward scenes what chance - Danny
and Sara have of defeating Legion and
future sequels well the movie sets up
several interesting possibilities the
first thing to consider is that in dark
fate the catastrophe happens over
several days when Legion and AI designed
for cyber warfare becomes self-aware and
begins its attack on humanity by turning
off the power grid
the next day humans attempt an EMP
attack on Legion that fails which leads
to a full world war by the third day
that was eventually followed by famine
which wiped out majority of humanity
with Legion then hunting down any
remaining human survivors as terrible as
that scenario is it's a slower wipeout
than nuclear annihilation and it allows
for a window of time where Danny and
Sara could attempt to prevent the
catastrophe from playing out in its
entirety something I've already
mentioned is how Karl is a great example
of how a machine can learn and become
something almost human with the ability
to make its own decisions rather than
follow a hard-coded set of rules this is
something that Sara and Danny both
witnessed and might investigate further
for example they could find a way to
change how legions machines operates so
they live together with humans rather
than kill them in fact there's a deleted
scene from Terminator 2 that's in the
extended cuts where the t800 explains to
John that his machine learning mode is
something that has to be switched on she
may learn stuff that you haven't been
programming with so you can be you know
more human my CPU is a neural net
processor a learning computer but Skynet
presets the switch to read only when we
ascend out alone does I want you to do
too much thinking huh no can we reset
the switch someone who might come in
useful for this is Sarah Connors contact
Major Dean the
electri officer who has an alliance with
sarah major Dean was only in dark fate
briefly handing over the EMP device to
Sarah but in an interview with IGN
director Tim Miller explained that Dean
was originally in more scenes and that
he's a military intelligence officer
whose worry of AI and it turned to Sarah
Connor to help him out on a few missions
by the way if you're is all confused by
the circular nature of time travel in
the Terminator franchises and the time
paradox as it creates well it's
basically different to the recent very
popular time travel movie Avengers
endgame in which time travel creates new
timelines and alternate realities in
dark fate in the Terminator franchise
time travel is a closed loop in which
change in the past rewrites the future
that's not how it works who who told you
that
Star Trek Terminator time doesn't work
that way changing the past does it
change the future even if logically this
seems to be impossible
doc fake director Tim Miller has said he
prefers this type of time-travel despite
the plot holes and paradoxes it creates
because it means higher stakes for the
characters even though Carl was damaged
beyond any likely repair and Doc fate
it's still possible for Swartz a
negative return in a sequel as a
brand-new character perhaps even a human
next time around James Cameron has said
it's unlikely Legion would attempt to
build an Arnold to t800 in the Legion
version of the future because that's a
different technological developmental
pathway however there could still be
more Arnold to t8 hundreds kicking
around that Skynet sent back first what
could be more interesting is if we met
the human being
Skynet based its t800 designs on in a
Q&A in 2007 Cameron said it has flashed
through my mind that there has to have
been a prototype that there has to have
been a guy that they grew the terminator
from and it presumably was a real person
at some point and did that person have
some sort of meaning to Skynet on why
they chose that one now what do you
think of Terminator dark fate and do you
have any theories or things you'd like
to see in potential sequels leave your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this then embrace your inner
movie lover by hitting that subscribe
button to get all my future videos
tapleft for more breakdowns of your
favorite movies or tap write for another
video
sure - like thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers